so I wanted to touch on the eye and very
important vitamins for the eye and not
just vitamins but a mineral and a
phytonutrient the first thing you need
to understand is that a lot of these
problems with the eye whether it's
macular degeneration or retinopathy --vs
or cataracts or glaucoma
they usually stem or get triggered from
oxidation high levels of oxidation
usually from too much blood sugar okay
that's why diabetics you see so many
problems at the eye or high levels of
insulin other things in the diet can
affect the eye but the big thing is the
sugar
okay so I've done all the videos on that
and then the high sugar also will
deplete you of certain nutrients as well
but these nutrients I want to mention
act as antioxidants so if you have
enough of these nutrients in your body
it will reduce the complications from
diabetes or high sugar or whatever you
have they basically have protective
properties okay so the most important is
about in my name without by the day
you're gonna have a lot of eye problems
vitamin A helps you see in the dark and
it can reduce night blindness and
prevent it basically and people that
can't see when they're driving at night
without vitamin A your tear ducts and
your mucous membranes around the eye
drive right up so you get dry eye
there's so many people like carrying
around this little solution to help
lubricate the eye when they need vitamin
A and also make note that you might need
more bile salts if there's a gallbladder
problem or a liver problem because you
need that to help you absorb vitamin A
without vitamin A you tend to get
cataracts and macular degeneration the
macula is the back part of the eye
alright then we get vitamin b1 which
gets depleted when you're diabetic when
you eat high carbohydrate diets when you
eat refined foods and also if you're
taking metformin by the way that will
deplete b1 without b1 your risk of
getting cataracts go way up and also
your risk for getting retinopathy
problems with the retina because b1 is
involved in keeping the outer
holding of your nerves intact that
myelin sheath so if you have any type of
peripheral neuropathy problems because
you're diabetic you want to take b1 but
you want to take it in a fat soluble
form as in benfotiamine okay then float
Amin is also good to penetrate the fat
layers of the eye and even the brain so
it's really good for something like this
if you catch it in time all right
b3 is good for a good kamma and all the
B vitamins that I'm going to talk about
you can take nutritional yeast to get
your B violence it's a good source but
glaucoma is high pressure in the eye
okay then we have zinc zinc is a very
powerful antioxidant it's a trace
mineral over two billion people on this
planet are deficient in zinc it's a very
common deficiency also in in agriculture
as well so it's one of the most common
but zinc allows vitamin A to work okay I
can do its job without zinc vitamin A
has a hard time creating its functions
or another point is that your eye is
loaded with zinc okay because zinc acts
as a cofactor or a helper in all these
different enzymes over a thousand
different enzymes dealing with proteins
without zinc you get an increased risk
of getting a cataract and macular
degeneration other than that you're
perfectly fine okay then we get
carotenoids which is not a vitamin it's
a final nutrient it's an additional
thing in plants and other foods that
give you health benefits like lutein Z
and thin you may have heard about eating
tomatoes for example as high in lutein
or kale or any type of leafy greens
because these carotenoids actually help
prevent macular degeneration and a lot
of other things
okay vitamin D actually can help reduce
the risk for cataracts it's a fat type
of vitamin this is a fat soluble vitamin
vitamin E is also involved but I didn't
want to mention that because there's not
a tremendous amount of research on the
eye with vitamin E maybe a little bit
here and there but vitamin E is a very
powerful antioxidant also so is vitamin
C from food very important but again I
didn't want to put that because I didn't
find a lot of research on that
alright vitamin b2 deficiencies can
increase your risk of cataracts and
macular degeneration as well and vitamin
b2 is a antioxidant for the nervous
system - so I did another video on this
related to Parkinson's very interesting
all right guys there's a summary make
sure you're getting these nutrients from
the food that you're eating
hey guys real quick I have a new healthy
keto eating plan for you just go to dr.
Berg comm it's right on the front page I
put a link down below download it it's
free check it out